bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
son los amos de los aires las estrellas
fugaces de las fuerzas armadas francesas
hablamos de los pilotos de la patrulla
de francia
sus aviones vuelan a 600 kilómetros por
hora y a 3 metros los unos de los otros
[Aplausos]
estos acróbatas del extremo están en
córcega para terminar los últimos
ajustes de su próxima representación
hoy como en el teatro hacer el primer
hilado de su obra
al son de la voz de su vida
que atienden el briefing previo al vuelo
de robots que sus artistas de los aires
llaman cada dos como se vio la música
mucho por lo que me hizo
yo diga
nos llevó todo
también se ha estimado
ya no sé
[Música]
mejor y que el pueblo es físicamente
agotador pero también mentalmente
podemos detectar algo olvidado mediante
ese trabajo en tierra y tenemos la
costumbre la patrulla nos dice algo que
no ha sido realizado durante el wifi y
será perfecto durante el vuelo y donkey
fotos y quizá también deben aprender a
estar en sus burbujas y concentrarse en
ellas en sus propios procesos de
mentalización y concentración sea cual
sea el entorno
saliendo del briefing los pilotos ya
están en el aire en su cabeza
cada uno maneja su concentración a su
manera
última mirada últimas palabras de
motivación entre los pilotos y sus
mecánicos este vuelo es decisivo para
todo el equipo
en las costas corsé gas el resto del
equipo escrita en las acrobacias desde
tierra a tus nueve observa a sus
coequipers es el piloto de reemplazo
un reemplazante de élite porque se trata
del aviador más experimentado de la
patrulla
debe poder instalarse de inmediato en
todos los puestos salvo el de líder
qué
los alfa jets hacen figuras una aura
luego ocurre la separación final
[Música]
para mí
muy bien logrados
sin descanso sin error el piloto
felicita a sus compañeros
aún queda camino por recorrer hasta el
final de esta gran aventura que es muy
bella y es un granito bravo a todos
una vez culminado el entrenamiento los
pilotos pueden vestirse de azul claro
símbolo de la patrulla de francia
desde su creación en 1953 sus miembros
conforman una confraternidad muy unida
este equipo de voluntarios seleccionados
él se renueva sin cesar haber
pertenecido a él es una referencia
elegida la raya de 30 años primer líder
de la patrulla de carroñeros georges
cánepa 30 años el segundo líder de la
patrulla de carroñeros shocks cánepa es
el 50 años después el de hace medio
siglo nunca ha parado de ver a sus
antiguos compañeros de vuelo no hay
muchos oficios en los que la gente
comparte 50 años después con el gusto
que tenemos nosotros en la fuerza aérea
había un ambiente de camaradería donde
estamos obligados a contar los unos con
los otros ellos influyen muchos
[Risas]
la patrulla de francia nació en plena
guerra fría cada país contaba con su
equipo nacional para demostrar su
dominio tecnológico y mostrar la
excelencia de sus pilotos
la patrulla de francia culmina su
presentación mediante gigantescos juegos
pirotécnicos haciendo estallar en el
cielo ramos en múltiples colores que
fiesta feriales elfos es
hoy algunos veteranos aún están al pie
de la pista en salud de cubo en medio de
oficiales superiores
antes de presentarse la patrulla de este
año aún debe obtener el aval del jefe
del estado mayor de la fuerza aérea que
dará inicio a un año de trabajo
[Aplausos]
despegando los pilotos saben que durante
20 minutos cada trayectoria cada figura
será escrutadas sin indulgencia por los
generales
aterrizando los hombres de azul claro
saben que lo hicieron perfecto
ahora deben hacer decenas de
presentaciones tanto en francia como en
el extranjero